[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody happy Friday it's
community Fridays I'm John Luke I'm
joined by Ben what's up
and we how's it going it's going good
Ben you know what it's Friday I'm ready
I'm ready to chill Vicki and what better
way to chill than in Final Fantasy 14
online yeah we got a bit by that Final
Fantasy bug we get hard by that Final
Fantasy bug I am I'm all in that Final
Fantasy now after playing seven and I
was like I should get back into 14 which
I immediately have not done that much
you've done a lot you're they're all
about 14 okay I'm I'm well over a
thousand hours played in it for sure but
a long way to go before I reach my
Warcraft player like hell but that's
fine
I like zip-zip is a good time yeah we're
just gonna hang out for the next hour
and a half place in Civ have a good time
Michael hi I'm was a huge advocate
getting this game is getting lunch but
after that he's gonna hop it in and play
with us as well so should get good time
and if you want to come hang out with us
you're more than welcome to we are in
ultros which is you got to be on the
primal data center which is kind of
unfortunate but if you're in that that
sort of thing what I gotta do is is come
on over ultra stand and try to find a
school I know we'll dance together or
something exactly so I'm level 14 which
is you were saying once I hit 16 we can
do some like right party raid stuff yes
some cool dungeons that's when you start
off getting more of the stuff you can
kind of do maybe we just do like a quest
or something I get to level me up here I
got uh I got to kill some skeletons
skeletons are cool I do like going after
skeletons I might switch my class to
something that's a little more along
your level so I'm not you know going to
too crazy with it okay but I think I
love with my blue mage with you so I'll
just that's good Ben do you want to uh
you want to take me to the to the quests
in your car oh yeah tell me tell me
where you gotta go I need
I need to remember how all these menus
work I can like leave a mark it's me
can I leave like a little thing for you
on the map or no so if if you there's a
way you can actually mark it in the chat
click on it it's how many word okay you
or I could I could also just look at
your your screen you could I know where
we gotta go anyway it's just gonna head
down this way after dark podcast this
morning was great as always heck yeah
Brandon Thank You Brandon
so how you doing it's good to see it
good to see everyone how's everyone
doing see see a Zack fair in here that's
a good call in the right place somebody
from Italy's hanging out welcome see
questline soundtrack personally the
combat game really got me we're talking
about Sarah we're talking about 14
because you can say that for both they
say this game so I assume they're
talking about 14 okay you're right click
on it and then say right yeah here we go
my favorite my favorite there is hello
how's it going so everyone watching the
stream it's it's me you boy
my favorite show about riding this car
with you is how incredibly sure I am
yeah you're my characters very big I
look like even in the car like I it
looks like you're my dad driving me to
school
can I drop you off at the cuesta zone
make sure you thanks dad yeah my dad so
I'm pretty sure it was down here I think
it's we
and take a quick quick little right and
yes this is indeed where we are suite
next regalia thanks Zach
appreciate it well probably's down
inside of there isn't it
maybe yes it indeed these boys we found
we found the skeletons they're here all
right I got again I got to remember
everything about how this game works I'm
gonna try to maybe make sure that you
don't get guy here cuz we've we kind of
just stumbled in the room like a bunch
of fools they're asleep
good so remember my blue mage like
hardly has any skills a little if any of
you guys hit shadow burners yet a Ben
you've done everything right yeah I'm
I'm burnin savages known and stuff and
Michelle bringers same way with you
Michael I assume you've done everything
at this point
oh yeah that's just me I'm the I'm the
one who needs to get caught up I died
no I kind of felt like that might be
what would happen yeah should I just
wait can you love me I can I can revive
you here in a second
no pull back here though guess what my
2019 game of the year would what was it
shower bringers baby boo your boy
Bachchan okay we're off to a rough start
at the beginning let's not drive the
regalia into the into the danger zone
okay I just got back from town yeah just
just go back to knock a mage cuz he has
two skills and one is to put things to
sleep when the other one is just my
basic skill okay let's try this again
yes
I just want the skillet lets me blow up
that's that's the one I'm here
get a face camp for Michael he's eating
you only want to still not see him
eating my webcam doesn't come in till
next week so then you can see my pretty
there you go you go yeah I like the idea
of setting it up though we get a full
party going okay I'm hanging out back
outside again I'm almost there I'll kill
this ground squirrel that seems easy
yup did it nailed it so I do that and
then I this should be a little I'm just
gonna gonna go with this cool this boy
all right let's do thing oh man you're
like a ninja I got I got my sneaking
suit on ready to go
is this pay up front or pay per month so
you do have to buy it and there is a
monthly sub but it's a little bit lower
than most subs are it's like ten dollars
a month if you only play one character
and you only really need one character
yeah
[Music]
summers best so I actually just started
leveling a summoner I've gotten them so
it'll not just start yes but I've been
leveling one and they're actually a very
good time so it's kind of difficult
because I love hitting buttons really
fast cuz I played a lot of Warcraft and
summoners the perfect class for that
some I'm just throwing spells left and
right also you get a little a little
different let's do this for real this
time
I'm scared gun kata these scorpions
really quick and we're not gonna we
aren't gonna have any problems with this
man everything's dying
I think questions are you getting credit
for it though I think I think we did it
cuz now just us to go back we got the
skeletons yep that was it we did it
okay we nailed it perfect these these
sweet gun kata skills just flipping all
over the place now wants me to go over
here okay go to excited noise oh it
makes me be very close to you to do that
okay make up it's literally just up the
road to the range little of a left
I need to remember how to mark stuff or
how to send links that you can you can
see stuff right right here ooh
oh it's these guys these guys see how do
I hop out oh I got you you press Z and
it'll it'll pop you out of it
gotcha okay how do you how do you throw
the the Lincoln for finance stuff or for
marking things
if anyone the chat knows let us know
that better no I'm just gonna so looking
up it's got the quest I could do screw
it why not okay
[Music]
well this is control right mouse that's
what okay so just on the map what are
the levels up to now eighty the the
level cap is at eighty honestok flaggin
in position I remember being things for
that alright let's do it here open up
your map and then I already already
centrally oh you have to share in the
chat I have to share it in the chat
should be in your window yeah now I can
now we're cooking that's weird they have
to share in the chat yeah there's a lot
of like old weird infrastructure stuff
this game has because it's been around
for a bit I'm really curious that it's
also gonna redo it all you're kind of
saying there I gotta redo the intro yeah
all this rumor born stuff should be
should be different anyway yeah should
be over here another Crested Tern in
Nice I feel like the XP I get from
killing monsters is way more that I get
from completing quests though which is
kind of weird
so you can you can chain kill things
which kind of helps with grinding stuff
a bit right yeah what up arrows good to
see you
yo arrow my guy there it is flip it I I
feel like I'm not like an opposer now
cuz I have this this bike because I
understand Final Fantasy 7 before I just
bought it cuz it's kind of like a like a
cheap way to get like a speed boosts but
do they have a catch-up mechanic for new
returning players there is like a a chat
that will help you get access to people
if you need to like run things and kind
of talk to them there for that there are
there's a campaign actually going on
right now for returning players so if
you don't if you played and you have an
existing
account you can actually play for free
bur like a ridiculous amount of time so
you don't have to pay it all just jump
on Michael's here but it's kind of
visible yeah he he doesn't have a webcam
the moment but he is here and when he's
done eating lunch he he's gonna jump on
we gotta go all the way now also we get
the sweet Final Fantasy 15 music yeah
it's pretty good I'm a fan and if you
can hear very loud on the stream talk to
this person so I don't see a person I
see a bunch of flowers oh god oh god I
can't okay well I need to kill the
flowers but let's just do this fate
really quick yeah so this is one of the
cool things about this game if people
don't know is that even though my
character is like a 65 I'm in a zone
that is like the same level as John Luke
and it actually lowered my level so I
could do the thing with them so that the
game basically makes all of its its
stuff accessible for everyone which is
really cool yeah it's nice
which can be a good thing in a bad thing
because whenever say for instance
there's like a required story dungeon
you have to do
anyone who's queueing up for like a
daily that's like a level eighty can get
put into your dungeon to help you run it
hey level up Oh Michaels on do you have
him on your friends list not okay
if you pass party leader to me I might
build what's what zone are y'all in we
are just below green Aniyah do we we
have a cool cool person from the chat
hanging out now oh are we are we are we
all together
I like this anyway I made you the party
leader uh-hmm
got it we got Michael in here I mean
there's a there's a bunch of Lala Phil's
playing a really cool song in Limassol
it means oh shoot there's a there's a
party happening I wonder because you
haven't been to Lim see yet
I've been anywhere if I teleport would
it take you with me find out here I'll
give it a go we'll see what happens if
it if it doesn't I did it say you were
unable to teleport like that wait a
second holy crap they're playing a
trails in the sky song for you oh I was
like the [ __ ] sounds familiar
yo no unable to teleport okay so you're
just gone now so I'll come back sort of
start heading out and I'll meet you
there
could we get a fashion show we should
put together another fashion show for
another house oh so good though
all right
so head back to gridania actually I
might be able to just pick up a teleport
even history yeah there we go oh I might
actually pick up Michael with this
teleport then would you want producer he
or she did take over Final Fantasy
franchise I know he's got interest in
doing the next Final Fantasy game is
that not confirmed I thought I heard
that that was happening that maybe maybe
I'm wrong I thought it might have been
too but I went back to look it up and
it's apparently just him saying that he
wants to unless I missed something
somewhere along the line but yeah I'd be
very down for him to do it but I want
like all the people who work on Zim's to
come together for it like I want I want
soaking to do the music I want I want
all of it I hear you right over here
gotcha in quests like Final Fantasy as
series has fantastic music of course
everyone knows but yo Final Fantasy 14
probably has the best soundtrack in the
series and that's people will never know
that's not stick play yeah yeah Ben I'm
curious how do you how do you feel about
a 7 remake soundtrack I loved it but I'm
also very I don't have the attachment to
the original I've heard some people say
some are really good and a couple people
in and then a few other tracks aren't as
good I've heard but I don't have a
friend to keep it like light and
spoiler-free you know the beginning when
an earth gives you a flower and it
starts playing her theme really softly
yeah uh I stopped had to take a breath
and then like almost started tearing up
okay that's so pretty good what it's
like yeah yeah cool pretty much anytime
Aris theme starts playing it's like a
gut-punch now in a good way
I'm definitely looking at the you should
look at the soundtrack after it's done
they've recorded like three versions of
every track like everyone has like
multiple versions of their theme they
have those in-game versions you can
collect it's good stuff yeah yeah it's
uh they turn the victory fanfare into a
salsa song what is happening in there
like I drink
it's so good at beds where is that oh
that's like a area should we do that
yeah I'm down here Oh hop hop in the car
why how do i I think I just go there I
don't know how I go though did you talk
to this fairy skipper guys maybe I
talked to him yep wait were you all that
we're down down south a bit I have to go
to a word I don't understand this at all
I see a Christian says what if guys just
got off work
Bluetooth in the car oh heck yeah I love
a love win like livestreams are great
cuz their purpose you can watch some we
can listen to them is like a pod like a
semi podcast
well I'm very into it then explain to me
exactly what screen I'm looking at
that's housing is that what it is
oh it's explaining me how I buy houses
yes so you're probably gonna teleport in
look at houses get really envious and
then realize you're never gonna be able
to buy one ever because the housing
markets really messed up in this game I
saw I saw an article about how like they
were suspending housing payment running
right suspending rape in-game and I was
like what are you talking about like at
first I thought they were talking about
actual says hot story on GameSpot calm I
thought their real subs in the game but
they were like no it's your sub
houston-how sub within your game sub oh
god it's like
if if you're if you own a house you have
to basically login like every month to
make sure the plot doesn't go vacant and
there you're suspended it for people who
couldn't pay to get on to play because
what how lame would it be if you finally
got a house after months of playing
Final Fantasy and you lose it because
the you know money wouldn't let you get
on okay well maybe let's not do that
then let's go okay here I guess not
but Michaels making make a sounds over
here doesn't that kind of sound like
Aaron Fitzgerald yeah a little bit dude
did you actually like pitch the voice to
try and try get that set up I mean hey
here everybody jump in the car go can I
wish that I can fight everyone to the
party so that we can all get in the car
but if you guys are joining us you
probably got your own mounts here you're
able to kind of follow along I guess I I
love how you're like peeking over those
yeah the Sun you're too big I can't see
you can't see where we're going you know
that's the story of my life you know
trying to do these these raid mechanics
you boys just too big all right let's
get out of here take these things out
really fast
should be something around here Oh
Teresa likes a turret it's true Bob's
calling out that Michaels voice telling
you to visit gamespot.com here we go
sweet promo it's just completely
obliterate them you know we're on the
fast track
we're I'm okay with that I this stuff is
it's real grindy and and not
particularly interesting so as much as
we love the loves if roma born is whoo
what level quests are we doing looks
like a level 13 show this we're kind of
we're kind of a long for it this is like
a a final fantasy 15 adventure we're
technically shall Lucas is the noctus oh
we break out the Coleman camping
equipment we should
oh here you should mark where we're
headed it's right it's right right here
I was just saying it's probably here I
mean it's gonna be a lot of me turning
oh my gosh I got this amount a little
while ago and I'm very into it from
speaking of Final Fantasy 7 the Ruby
weapon fight it plays a very good song I
want that shark the sharks eluded me for
too long do you think we'll see a day
when Final Fantasy gets fully outsourced
to Western devs I don't know I feel like
a fantasy why it's like one of those
things that you did they did you'd want
to keep kind of with the people who know
what they're doing
right
it's a wacky it's a wacky thought um I
guess this one you just have that emote
out on a bar way cool all right I guess
we're going this okay all right
stack up I do like that you're doing it
in say chat so that other people can
market to that along with us oh whoops
no no that's that's good oh okay this is
a good thing because now they they can
also mark it on their Maps and see where
to go I don't fancy eleven it's still up
and running what yeah dude
there are a lot of people who like
playing final fantasy xi I not one of
them
homeboy Mike Williams at us gamer just
did a feature on it there you go
yeah I remember in high school a lot of
people being really in the final fantasy
xi I think I remember playing it a bit
but I I don't remember like but I'm
curious now if I went back and gave it a
go I would go I'm wondering if we have
to go up or if this is worth looking at
I'm it just says report to the central
shroud and then it gave me like a thing
over here so I'm not really 100% sure so
let's set up this tree and see what
there is
damn drift King drift cape flippin
taking it all over the place
this isn't where cars are supposed to go
you see anything around here
[Music]
you're hit-the hit-the map button really
quick mm-hmm so I'm gonna look at your
screen wait am i screen tell me what I
need this means so it is just kind of
like a big green zone
it just says just like show up yeah oh
shoot it's it's pickle Rickster
oh god the phoniest should I ever seen
have you seen that meme on
I think it's Tech Talk where people like
do impressions of other characters and
it's to them telling people about pickle
rick and how they think it's really i'm
into it but also i don't know if i'm
into you I should send you one later
this one where somebody does an amazing
bayonetta impression oh it's like
Bayonetta telling I think they grow Don
or something about tech it's like the
stupidest ie but it's really do love
great Bayonetta content so that's that's
good thing so there anything or what is
the actual objective set it just says
report to central shroud hmm there's
probably someone here that we've got to
talk to maybe up over this way there's
gotta be a in the green circle just
someone to talk to yeah are you wait
that's not your main quest is it think
so cuz your main question be in the top
left now I'm telling you what's next my
main quest is called a dangerous
proposition ooh that sounds like a good
time you should are you trying to do the
bean quest we could yeah should I try
and do that yeah okay pretty much just
mainline that stuff I don't really need
too much the the outside things
basically doing the main quest and then
anything that has a plus sign okay well
that's
yeah should probably just make the trip
over - what if we just made the running
took you all the way over to blimps and
then you can hear that concert that's
happening apparently I don't know if
it's still going on but usually this
stuff is going on there but I mean we
can do the main questline and maybe get
to the first dungeon now we've got to go
back up through Danya so we gotta go
this way back to town early it wasn't a
quest I was trying to I don't know what
I was trying to do then it's 11
I see though that those are kind of like
the the quest that stay in the zones
that let you do like you do them over
and over if you want you know you have
to activate them through your journal
but it's just basically like protect
this thing or kill this thing
and it's basically Metz you level up low
levels fat yeah it's a good show I said
I saw it in the in the chat are good
friends running around with us I have my
my chat window up like half over the
screen so I couldn't see the other half
of them the quest log to see the the
card so you should just be able to run
up insult gridania it's in the back
right
so I didn't spend a lot of time in this
zone leveling because my character
started in old ah so I got like the big
city with the really like moody piano
music all the time it's all chill vibes
up in here it's true it's people out
here they like the plants
I would run so much faster than me
[Music]
okay so I think I go in here yeah
[Music]
why is the car burning I hope the car
isn't burning I'm seeing the live-action
series by Sony Oh God are we talking
like a Final Fantasy live-action series
I realized that I hadn't been looking at
the chat for a while use the aether
right shards travel it's a good call I
don't know what would a throat's
gianluca's yet i guess is the thing okay
i guess i go this way heck yeah ghosts
follow you I guess because I'm sure it's
a whole bunch of around talk to the
ferry skipper I think so cuz I need to
go the east shroud yeah that's that's
the thing I'm pretty sure you need bloom
Pierre yep that's the one
[Music]
wait which quest are you doing I it
should whatever says next main scenario
quest unless I'm not doing the main
quest I'm doing something else oh we
should probably be doing salvaging the
scene that's the main quest the one
under it is your class oh I'm doing the
class quest
I know salvaging the scene was all the
way back there oh god I messed up looks
fine I mean we could do the class quest
cuz it'll probably get you like a thing
too
we're here we might as well run to it
right yeah I guess so cool - I guess ow
wait where'd y'all go now what's of the
honey oh yeah yeah ah the sweet sweet
bloom pure I think mm-hmm
yeah here I can just run in hop in
unless it's like right now it's like
right here Oh
okay I'm doing like stuff for the
Lancers skill that makes more sense but
that wouldn't be main class stuff it'll
probably prompt you to like leave the
group at one point if it takes your
weight that's fine
oh I'll do that I'll do stuff with you
guys it'll be quick but I do like that
you just got like a like a like a gang
of people walking behind as I'm doing
these menial low rank quests a key item
I appreciate all these people just
hanging out with me while I'm doing this
stuff so you're getting traffic
controlled and he's dead got him that
big tree is no more boom Michael just
slam the ground real hard I should do
more my ninja hmm I am playing monk
right now cuz thematically fitting yeah
that's definitely fair okay it's making
me go back to central shroud we can we
can switch over to the main quest so
it's probably a better better call I
like it
[Music]
oh there's a merchant and bender over
here perfect actually forgot to repair
my gear so I was looking for one while
we were running around talking but
literally the last thing I was doing was
trying to fight like a savage fight
earlier this week here we go all right
where we going this way
yeah right behind you
or are you going back to the secret
Dania no okay no no I need to go over
here so leave a mark it's literally that
pier where you're at before I feel oh
cool
fish it's fun don't hop on it Michael is
he getting his I'm out
you drop the marker real quick I love it
right sorry I forget that I always need
to do that it's all good
where we going down south see I've been
trying to do you Rica for that that that
t-rex and whoa it's not you break us up
Eureka is the final fantasy xi zone and
the game and it's a lot especially now
that it's like old content so it's hard
to find people to do it with but I want
that dinosaur
[Music]
sick of take a back road here I love
these two small cat girls in the back of
your car it's a heck of a thing we're
almost there
Eureka is a huge chore to do puts here X
mounts alright we've made it so think
you probably just have to go in here and
look at it okay so I think for this I
need to I've been doing those those
Hildebrand quests hell yeah yeah they're
so good they're so I really hope they
they add more soon boy needs them give
dinosaur hold on them you sub real quick
oh there there a few dinosaurs you guys
good all right where are we going
salvage some cargo get that cargo
on the youkai mounts are available
anymore I still got the default whisper
go okay it's down over here
I had to get this oh wow it's it's not
the like super heavy grinding one that
glows but it it serves its purpose is it
in the song yeah it's like just south
okay I'm like halfway to getting my
rathalos mount - what's down here I just
need to find more people to grind it out
with because my static that I raid with
has a hard time doing getting them to do
Monster Hunter cuz I want to do it more
what it's right here yeah it's all this
fall on cargo oh I mean I don't even see
it oh we're here oh it's a giant lumber
toon what I got I got it
[Music]
now I gotta go all the way over here oh
man this is so fun
no the Fenrir bike is more than just
like a really cool bike because it
actually gives you a like a speed boosts
in all the zones so like when shadow
bringers came out I was able to go
faster than everyone else everyone got
bikes do the bike is a cool time got a
head up hold on I got too excited I
thought you're already in I'll follow I
miss all could teleport there it's true
so if you if you click on the the right
thing you just use teleport in what it's
like in the the area where the thing is
if you click on the the blue 8th right
it'll actually let you teleport to it
100 kicking yeah yeah yes we can we can
make their own too but it's it's up to
you I don't know
it's definitely quicker to teleport Oh
Drive it's fine alright we are just kind
of taking it easy Michael how are you
doing I feel like I haven't chatted with
you in forever
[Music]
dude same yeah I'm you know I got so
many JRPGs on deck son I'm good dad if
you've locked me in a room for like the
next three months I'm good
funny you should say that I feel like
I'm in the same boat and so has been yo
dude he started with Dragon Quest and
it's just been a spiral since I still
have Dragon Quest to play I'm thinking
about playing the original 7 now you
should definitely play the original 7 i
i i started that up just to kind of be
like oh yeah i'll just see where it goes
and then I accidentally 40 hours of that
game in like a week I think it was just
I kept going and I didn't
stop
[Music]
oh look at the little fish people yeah
you're so cute that's it so much mommy's
got a spin old ponytail oh this this is
the beer horse it's the the keyring Wow
yeah I have to talk to people oh my gosh
yeah there's there's a lot of talking in
all right I'll go do that you guys have
a freaking party ooh I'm so I'm so here
taking stock in my mounts I guess let's
follow you around I got that bug ah poor
music playing now Michael what uh what
JRPG are you thinking about playing next
I thought you were like dabbling in like
four of them at once
like six of them at once yeah which one
are you gonna do you think you're gonna
like commit to well I'm still I'm in the
middle of seven remake right I'm hooked
on third I still have more stuff to do
in 14 here
I just got soccer Awards I'm gonna start
it tonight and I really want to finish
trails in the sky and pick cold steel to
back up heck yeah
so those are all the games and I'm
playing I'm very very envious of me
soccer Ben we're also talking about
playing thirteen again it's just it's
hope as I just did like hope yeah
what's wrong oh he's the Ken of Final
Fantasy 13 yeah but you know his mom
yeah okay it's literally the same ya
know think about it it's the exact same
plot seed for beating except hope has
silver hair yes
[Music]
like thick also think about the way hope
has a crush on lightning in the same way
that ken has a crush and does P 391 yeah
yeah
same [ __ ] Wow boom wolf says how much is
the game it actually has been going on
sale you could probably get the game and
all the expansions for like 30 bucks
that's what I don't want 14 yeah I think
the complete edition is 40% off so there
we go
the only thing to know when you are
buying it is wherever you buy it is
where you're stuck with it unless you
want to buy it again yeah Steve version
there's a screen extract version and
then there's the PS worker yes
steam and PC are not the same yes and I
think the version that's typically on
sale on their website is the square
annex version because I that's the
version I have say I'm gonna check the
steam store and see if it's because I
know it was on sale I'm gonna see if
it's on sale on Steam still on sale on
Steam but right now oh no it's only for
people who returning so that doesn't
doesn't do anything for new people yeah
just buy it everywhere I actually
because I had I played originally on ps3
then I played on ps4 and then someone
had gifted it to me on Steam so I could
make the jump to PC oh I forgot this
game was originally on ps3 yeah it there
are a lot of limitations you can still
see in this area of the game that are
specifically because of it being on ps3
I've been I got a new spot to go we're
gonna do a new zone for stealing back a
stolen egg let's get that egg I'm not
sure this has to do at the main quest
but it's the thing I'm supposed to do oh
I hope pickle Rick's does someone in the
chat
a little I love when I cheer I have to
turn my whole car I love the way the car
pivots Yates physics man here late link
up the zone where we got it
Oh God I like I do it and then I just
forget to hit enter in the ain't no
thing
alright let's roll out everybody got it
we gotta get back those eggs whoo it's
actually really cool to see cuz I don't
I don't come out into the zones very
often anymore but seeing a lot of people
out like actually leveling and doing
stuff cuz to me it's all people crafting
in yo more or like the main big cities
oh wait a minute
okay let's let's just kind of kill our
way in here cuz we don't want to get all
the skeletons again so think you're
going back here yeah I definitely am she
might be getting your first Earth Malby
no the dungeon I think oh I think this
is the indention I think Sasha is the
first one what gives
in limbs so something else back here we
need to touch on unless it's back behind
it not down here it says subdue the
thief that might be it might be behind
it
I might not actually listen head back
upstairs I'm gonna get in my car inside
of this cave we're gonna peel out of
here
[Music]
yeah that's uh that's the wild thing too
about this is I haven't done this stuff
literally since ps3 was like the thing
right like 10 years ago
any of this you see anything over here
yeah yeah it's a coupe Oh over here I'm
gonna try get these guys off you really
quick there we go
level sink is in effect if you're above
the maximum level will be synced as
follows level 18
it's gotta be done alone oh yes you
gotta you know leave oh that's good no
it's all good
tu tu tu tu thing all right well we'll
wait for you out here
it'll be like the right level for this
instead level 18 I'm only level 15 you
could do it so 14 wait what are you what
are you doing I I don't know is I gotta
get an egg back for a chocobo or
something Brielle I need to leave the
party so give it a go in worst case if
I'm doing it I'm doing a thing you got
you all to go we'll all hang out here
and do something ah yes I see yeah get
that egg get that egg can it fly yes how
did you get that mouth the the car it
was from a like a Final Fantasy 15
crossover event for a little bit you had
to go and help noctus cuz he
accidentally stumbled into this universe
and then he's like CID steals the plans
first car and which instead of making
which one the 14 CID 14 SIDS great he he
looks like a young Kenny Rogers no he do
he really do he's got that energy too
damn okay together that's as soon as I
saw him like oh shoot
look at this man damn r.i.p though it it
did cost a lot of MGP I wasn't idiot and
grinded it out for like a day I don't
recommend it
man only guys did your cool chairs I
don't got any cool chairs at all brass
have we tried Valery I have you've been
playing a lot of it it seems Michael
yeah I'm a felon proton me and so did
you it are killing it bro
even especially he's really good
that boy is good at a shooters he's very
good at shooters sure though eventually
put in the Mach station yeah I I kind of
hopefully do there they're pretty good
at kind of bringing events stuff that
people might have missed back into a
place where you can get it all right
then it'll cost a bit hey you're already
back look at that see what was in that
bag you get those get those eggs yeah I
need a I need a gram right now I got put
into a cinematic look at this bird
[Music]
[Music]
all right I got the a which is a
pugilist your your on that the pugilist
life right now
actually I just switched to ninja there
you go
I like that you've got like different
themed outfits it seems for kind of what
you're doing that's pretty good
[Music]
I'll write my joke ball start oh we
should go to the gold saucer wait what
the gold sauce is in this game Oh a lock
until like later later though you're
toast toast on that point
oh yeah you go okay as on the way anyway
yeah you have to change pork chop I'm
like so far behind on this it's you know
it's all good I I'd say like you can
definitely try to rush it but it's I
think it's a better game if you kind of
take your time with it I think I just
need to play it more regularly as there
is the issue yeah there we go
you've made it here is your egg sir here
is your egg in this trying time what
level is the quest again 14 okay
low 15 is the quest should be when we
get the first dungeon let's do it
I don't know how long it's gonna take
though I will say oh we can look up the
actual quest for it and see what the
requirements are in worst case just
drive him to it if he meets it come true
eventually it'll like lead him to it
[Music]
I love the the look of the relic acts a
lot for warriors
[Music]
true I don't I haven't been doing that
firmament stuff so I don't even have my
my umbrella I'm a fool leveled up why
you got a new a new piece of gear -
that's like looking good nice nice
the next quest is called dread is in the
air let's see how fast you 15 or 14 has
a story yeah the most recent expansion a
lot of people are saying is one of the
best written final fantasy stories that
has come out since like seven like hell
yet there it is there it is
you know if you wanna hear me and been
on the verge of tears listen to an old
episode of GameSpot after dark okay I
just I just need to go back to so good
and good Dan yeah I could just pop back
so port it up yeah yeah it's all coming
together
oh you did a return as did free I got
some money it's true and you love it
when it's free it's gonna take the skin
drugs you're gonna have to talk to
people anyway
indeed I mean Michaels already in the
car I can't like abandon him you know
speaking over the the side of the seat
bring Michael back on the podcast there
it is Brandon said it himself got to do
it now we gotta go to hit up Jake no
I've been I've been kicked off the
podcast so that's that on that the wool
start up our own podcast with all we
talk about Zevon in Jeremy's JRPG
podcasts there's something to that game
so I used to have a JRPG podcast
actually
pick it up fool I think I think it they
stopped doing it either right before
right after I started working here it
was called airship Oh
I was like Peter Brown Alexa ray Korea
and I think Justin hey well damn I would
love to hear Peter
talk about games again man Peter left
right when I realized Final Fantasy 7
was the game that I loved and now I I
know I can't I can't go to him and tell
him about that it's been fun talking to
people like like Nick Nick Sherman he
was like a huge fan and about the game
but yeah I didn't get to talk to to
Peter about it
uh-huh oh yeah I'm so happy for Nick
Sherman yes that remake him out a Stan
and he's been helping out with a lot of
our content around that so yeah he's
been putting in a lot of words yeah
almost every single video that I've had
to publish his head him at the top of
the task because he's coordinating it
yeah in fact he's if you finish the game
we have a Easter Egg video that I am
currently working on that I'll have
finished today and then should be
hopefully going up either later today or
tomorrow and that should be really cool
you should finish the game though before
you watch it because it is super spoiler
heavy
yeah don't I'm just avoiding all those
spoiler things I'm excited for when I'm
able to like so I can't even load up a
YouTube like yeah yeah totally
like the algorithms already caught that
I'm slightly interested in in Final
Fantasy and I haven't checked that since
I started like playing through the
original 7 then into remake so like yeah
so hey do you want to know what's up
with the this big part in remaking but
don't do this to me
yeah that's just the YouTube algorithm
man it really screws you over it did it
with spoilers because it it's always a
devil Leon with Yakuza bringing the good
word to people but I also don't I don't
know if I need to see all the boss
fights over for Yakuza level it's not we
don't even know when it's coming out
here I got a delivery over a letter I
forgot that the whole reason I started
playing JRPGs this year was to get ready
for yeah cuz of seven and now I've like
shot past my JRPGs to play RPG I love it
though JRPG cast we should bring it back
I mean like it's perfect we'll just talk
about how much we love Final Fantasy
games that were finally playing let's
take user recommendations for what ones
we should play next you know I have I
would love to talk about the seven
different RPGs I'm currently juggling
because I literally I talked to my or
actually Ian Ian Kelley former cbsi
engineer that's my guy yeah he's
actually he's actually logged in right
now he's part of the free company no
nice he's one who got me into trails and
cold steel dang I really hit up trails
but also I'm already looking at I'm
looking at playing Final Fantasy 8 10 10
to 13 and 20 mm we didn't even say 9 I
it's not what I should hit up because I
trust you Michael
9 is really good mine's really good
maybe it wasn't here I couldn't find the
guy oh good yeah I'm thinking about
hitting up I'm definitely wanna hit up
some of the ps1 ps1 games and I gotta
play Final Fantasy II or enough fancy I
got to start persona 5 royal yes that's
taking a big backseat because I realized
that I'm a Final Fantasy guy now and you
want to play all of them I'm trying to
replay a bunch of Final Fantasy games
too and I missed out on 12 and 13 and
now I'm already invested in 13 so yeah
III never play or I played 13 because it
was the first one I played and I never
finished it so I like playing 7 makes me
really want to go back and replay
13 and likes a [ __ ] see how I feel about
it
see man that's insane we got enough
material we could you can do episodes
for four years it's true this the the
content that keeps giving
oh wait a bit hold on I've got I've got
to pass these off you you can give you
could do it to this from Romo you could
you can't you give them to him you to do
it
I got a I got a code at the Guardian
tree the guardian tree tree for
Guardians thank you God I think you got
some some cool things out here you Bobby
wants to get hit with a trade window oh
I did I think I maybe just in you did I
might have accidentally clicked out of
that give it a sec look at all these
people and this bunny guy and that bunny
girl oh yeah they uh they it used to be
that to unlock like certain classes
you'd have to level up to different
classes to get skills from both but they
took that out of and a couple expansions
again yep gifts for me yeah wow thank
you go to a cool parasol in there you
got a mount in there flippin they got
you the hook Oh Brandon just doesn't
they picked the place with cross tag
nice 4.4 bucks yeah switch see now
you've got it you've got to get to like
what is it 25 so you can ride them out
now mm-hmm how do I activate that
parasol somebody gave me um that's a
good question if I had one I'd tell ya I
don't know if it's like an emote or if
it's like an item you've gotta activate
I mean I activate it and said now you
got it but I don't know what that is it
amount I haven't got mine yet but I
think that activates like a pet in
actually mode too
oh she's been your inventory you have
any of my actions and traits so it sits
in here your skill section so go press P
and it should be in there somewhere
[Music]
geez general or extras it's an others
there you go extra ah here we go
there now you're ready for whatever
rains there you go
ah look at that don't even matches like
you are here color to you
Wow well together heck yeah man how do i
emotes how do I do that emotes are you
click it you can click on the like to
face button and it'll bring up the
emotes option to face button it's in the
social button a social one
oh these emotes somebody gave me we
still gonna find it there we go
now that to my favorites eat bread eat
bread I'm I got ya bring I might have to
drop the yep there we go now I'm eating
some bread see now you're you're eating
you two haven't eaten this entire time
I've been playing my characters that
ever eaten food didn't know how to its
its own owns the social slump oh thank
you oh for social
well this is fantastic thank you
everybody yeah looks on the way we gotta
get to the point where you can ride them
out yeah here I'm gonna fast travel to
the meadow and the central shroud sounds
good
I do like that when you teleport it
offers me to teleport with you
oh that's very nice yeah some just
follow right along okay I think I marked
it already on the map for you I don't
know if you see it or if I need to redo
it I think so it's it's around to the
left side of the map right yeah West
yeah let's do it
Sydney jump thrusters there
[Music]
[Music]
I think we have to go up here and then
back around we'll find out
it's an adventure
[Music]
these guys are a much higher level then
you should be dancing around with that
thing's literally call the death gaze my
death gaze you might need to like be
down there actually yeah yep there it is
I see it hold on to your butts we've
made it yep alright right here so the
fun thing about fall damage in this game
is as long as you don't have oh you have
to exit the party again looks like I
have to leave again to do it as long as
you're not being followed by an enemy or
have an enemy around you you can fall
off of anything and you'll take all your
health away except for one unless see
how a rope yeah you should you're safe
to jump off of things
that's what I'm saying it's kinda nice
out there is definitely above this level
brought it back down though gotta fight
these guys
I'm really jealous of that Rathalos I
need I need to get people to zoo monster
hunter with me all these guys yeah
jumping off of the the tower and kudani
went and still survived I also really
wish that you could like duel people out
in the open you wouldn't have to go to
like the PvP zone to do it so we could
do we can do cool cool like tiny fights
yeah the rat fight is a lot easier I
still like that they kind of like took
the whole there aren't necessarily
classes in it thing and made it like a
monster hunter fight it's the people
living out a sweet anime beach episode
right now I love it oh oh my god you're
right
yeah I'm living for it this is the thing
well there it is yo there it's getting
spicy I love it I need to get back in so
I can see this it's too much
samurais currently level 70 level
innocent dancer for Shadow bringers come
back another samurai that's a good a
good call I have a friend who just
started leveling up their dancer the gun
280 like maybe this week and they've
been having a pretty good time with it
dancer seems like a good time good -
good old gold cool buff and everyone oh
yeah
fishing you fish I'm here for it
I can totally fish to kill time why
didn't I think of that that's that's so
that's so smart
this was a fun easy job to learn I I've
uh well I got any fish um iíve got my
barred up to eighty and I really like
playing them I really want to get my
sorcerer leveled up it's weird because I
like from all my time in Warcraft I
played a melee DPS back then but for
some reason I'm kind of gravitating more
towards like the ranged DPS and the
casters and soo
you had a fishing rod Michael nope
dang dude and I haven't done any Fisher
quests we got a we got to do the fishing
raid with you guys if we can get
Charlotte to limp there's a fishing raid
yeah you all get on a boat except it
starts in 45 minutes so it'll be after
the the time that we're done we'd have
to catch it like right when it starts
down the next time we streams if that'll
be Vega we do well we'll start our
stream off with a fishing raid afraid to
go near Summoner at higher levels look
way too complicated for me
there are a lot of buttons there's a lot
of stuff to maintain but man when when
you get like in the flow of doing them
I'm only like like a 70 something it's
if it feels good manager goon for Roma
born heavensward
samurai for storm blood samurai for
storm blood makes sense
oh my god I caught a bony tongue thanks
oh no this guy is summoning a bad
looking thing you got it you gonna stop
him
classic final fantasy no game some I
think it's just turned down really low
yeah
the shipping game sound earlier oh look
at that that's sweet boy inside of that
drum quite a dancer bard until now most
pretty simple jobs yeah I like the the
bards like keeping thoughts up while
you're you're doing like cool cool song
stuff management it's it's fun I mostly
did it just so I could play music with
the performance stuff it's a good time
so I got my Scout trumpet now do i
messing this gargoyle up
heck yeah
[Music]
did you you've got like your own boss
fight going on right now with normals
going down
I got them I'm actually really relieved
seeing how many people are here
yeah cuz if if we ever like actually are
able to do more zip stuff it means we
got enough people who are on this data
center that are willing to watch our
stream acts like it actually pull people
in to do things that's what I want
also John Luke I don't know if you
joined already but the giant bomb free
company is the biggest one on this data
center so I would love to they are dope
- I think he need you can you need to do
a quest to unlock housing first I think
I have that requested lock housing so I
do that and then I can join yeah I think
so because they have to introduce the
idea grand companies in free company CIA
these guys I remember them
I look at them with all their bows and
arrows hmm
it's still not really sure it's going on
in this game story mode but Roma borns
that's it's you guys keep saying it for
like everything it's it's not like the
most interesting or best but it's it's a
good it's a good setup in a groundwork
there's a lot of like hey you've done
this thing do it do it again but with a
different flavor this time right yeah
yeah the game audio has been turned it
also I don't think this stuff is voice
acted no it's not this spider-man before
that all happened it's like really quiet
for whatever reason Haga Gila party you
know what we've got we got the extra
spot and here you gave you gave him a
cool umbrella so I'll just just invite
you to well we'll hang out we'll be
great so I wish we could invite like
everyone to like a giant group yeah
the robe or does definitely get better
later up its is definitely a drag for
the kind of beginning parts there but
you back to the party oh thank you
you got it so now I think I just need to
go back to town yep okay I'm heading up
that teleport oh look who's here
I didn't realize it's in the room again
oh yeah it's the perfect stream now
we've got it we did it we did it
everyone oh wow he's so good he's right
you know
yeah go what Oh check out the stream one
Benz cat showed up ah oh oh oh my gosh
he's got very big eyes I like him a lot
here shoot you teleported anyway you'd
sit back to the gridania yep okay I'll
take I'll take us all there I got you
guys look my cat he's just sleeping on
the couch she's nice and cozy no I wish
I had I don't got one dude uh he's a
he's a good mm okay he likes watching
that's what I want to hear
I want a JRPG cat yeah cat that likes to
hang out while I play JRPGs personify
Burrell has a very good JRPG cat it's
true that's true
it's very very true your railroad back
there I'm gonna hang out over here we've
got someone playing some music
[Music]
see huh Bob Jim says why no pet jean-luc
just oh well going on yeah well for
starters the my previous apartment
didn't allow us to have pets our current
apartment does although you gotta pay a
little extra which is a bummer although
I think that's kind of standard around
here but no we just haven't had a chance
to you know not really sure what we want
to get a lot a lot of thinking about it
we'd like to though part of the issue is
is with cats for me I love cats but I'm
allergic to a good amount of them so I
would need to make sure I have a cat
whose fur I'm not allergic to
[Music]
yaaay I think my favorite thing about
Final Fantasy 14 is besides the stellar
soundtrack and the great characters and
the fun gameplay is I like how
everyone's characters kind of look
different like the they give you enough
customization options were I don't think
I've ever seen a Rogen and that looks
like mine yeah yeah your character is
especially looks very unique it's like I
like it a lot like even in this Jang
people I'm hanging out with right now
none of these characters look the same
and it was kind of weird coming from
Warcraft where it's like ah that human
has human face right yeah this game is
good character customization PSO pso2
that's great character creation very
good yeah little boy what are you doing
well you just woke up from your nap
that's why you like this I got you
just love that the lighting during the
time of day changes if the hours go yeah
I I kind of Miss having like the the
day/night cycle that was tied to real
life but it's nice to be able to see
both day and night them yeah it's a good
trade-off little dude I can't I leave oh
there we go no favorite things the
weather I'm singing in the rain we're
listing the Sun of the ambience yeah I
also love that the the rain actually
affects like gathering classes and stuff
came back oh well dude dude
gonna rock this parasol
I'll just don't save your bars in the
top-left oh yeah you mess with your UI
and put them there yeah yeah like I also
like that you can change your UI around
like that yeah I moved it up there we'll
see if if you know once the game
actually starts to get a little more
intense in the combat if that's a good
choice or not but for now I like it
yeah can we see some fighting he'll
probably have to go fight here in a bit
yeah well no we're actually getting
close to the end of the stream yeah
right is this another one that kinda
just flew by and I feel like we didn't
really get to accomplish much much just
kind of hanging out having a good time I
gotta talk to Michael for a hot minute
yeah I'm saying how I'm happy he came on
oh yeah
checking slack for a minute yeah that's
the thing if I if I didn't have anything
else going on today I would be like you
don't screw it well I'll just keep
playing for a while why not but I do I
do gotta take care of that that Easter
Egg video I'm doing a seven remake and
13 comparison articles so I need to
finish are you doing a comparison
article interesting yeah I'm sure they
can't appreciate he's having a good time
your that sounds cool dude oh I would
like oh my god that
this is just this is just me putting the
can as a streamline can we cuts a
full-screen on Ben unfortunately not but
apparently you've got mail too he is
just out of it oh and someone's trading
he amounts again yeah you're getting the
the real hookups dude what are you doing
hey you know it's all good look at that
look over there
there now I should all be able to see
Ben's cat oh he's he's just showing like
he's not really doing much of anything
oh he's now it's time for him to leave
oh he's out of here he's gotta go look
at the window there's a bunch of birds
out there Oh
at least we got a full cam on the kitty
what's the cat's name so his is like
legal name is Beauregard or boo for
short legally but I call him Albert
whisker because that's what we were told
we were gonna name him when we got him
and I was lied to
ah so you're like well you know what I'm
gonna call him that anyway yeah oh look
he came back I don't understand make up
to my little dude here come on go on up
there that's what
you need I'll find a way next time for
the stream to set up easy easy switching
to cat can let the cat cams kind of like
a surprise thing they never know when
it's gonna happen Zach Lee but I'll find
it I'm gonna make it work actually
thought I was in my room alone until he
just kind of walked across my desk total
screen Chris so they made it up for me
actually with the the next cat we got
because we actually have to uh then we
name the other one Leon so now I get to
like Ashley Graham yell Leon whenever he
does anything that's pretty good so this
is a pretty good kind of concession for
that should probably be paying attention
where you're at oh you're walking back
this way perfect I'm just doing a lot of
busy work uh you guys ever tried Guild
Wars 2 I did for a long time I like that
game I think I just like zip just a
little bit better though I think there's
just more to zip also zip has there's a
boss fight against a robot that full
crowns itself and it's ska music this is
so much a red quest marker major to
Louisville oh yeah this is very true
this guy's about to take you for a wild
ride hmm sweet way to spell fashion Wars
just its final fast fashion
14 world of fashion craft why are you so
we should probably close up this dream
hopefully you guys had a good time just
hanging out with us playing Final
Fantasy talking about JRPGs yeah I had a
good time I had a good time as well
Michael thank you for coming on your I
love hearing your voice and I don't get
to it enough anymore [ __ ] me too man
I love hearing my voice big sis well I I
definitely feel you on that yeah thanks
for joining guys if you know it's gonna
be a little bit of a dry spell for the
next couple a couple of weeks I mean you
don't be coming out so if you guys want
us to ever play anything like this just
let us know you know you can you can hit
me up on Twitter I'm just at John we
psyche I think Ben's a pen djenka
Michael is at Michael P hi um talk to us
about JRPG [ __ ] to see which one of
the 10 JRPGs I'm playing on the day
it'll be it'll be
do you have like specific days assigned
to like a it's Thursday so you know I
don't know depends on depends on what
I'm drinking that's fair okay that's I
like that that's a good way to do it
yeah yeah dry spell coming up that means
I think that that means that for me
fries is basically open for a bunch more
zip or a bunch more fighting game
whatever people want to hang out and
play so yeah look forward to that and
until then we'll see you guys next time
bye bye
right thank you for hanging out
peace